so what I want to do here is make a
video answering the question who is Jay
Garrick and what I'm hoping is that at
the end of this you'll have a strong
understanding of why his character was
made as well as his origin and how you
as a pivotal part of DC's launch of the
multiverse
created by Gardner Fox in January of
1940 Garrick was introduced due to the
popularity of Superman because a Man of
Steel stood as the first superhero in
comic book form the sergeant interest
regarding comic books led DC to produce
a series of other characters who
remodeled after Superman's role in
fighting on behalf of the common man but
had their own distinct abilities that
separated them from one another while
Superman was an amalgamation of strength
speed and durability like Batman Aquaman
Wonder Woman and the Green Lantern Alan
Scott Jay Garrick represented an aspect
of Superman by demonstrating the element
of speed in his first appearance during
flash comics which actually served as an
anthology series introducing the other
Golden Age heroes like Cliff Cornwall
Hawkman and Johnny Thunder Jay Garrick
is introduced as a college student in
Keystone City with a fondness for a
woman named Joan who doesn't return his
affections as she explains Jay Garrick's
combination of athleticism and
intelligence could make him a star but
because he doesn't apply himself rather
than being the best member of the
football team instead he's considered
the weakest member by his teammates the
coach and everyone in the school however
the reason for Jay Garrick's lack of
interest in athleticism is showing when
his intelligence is demonstrated while
working with an unnamed man simply
referred to as the professor while this
original story refers to the professor
NJ working on a substance called hard
water because the introduction of Jay
Garrick came in 1940 and coincided with
the dawn of the Manhattan Project and
the development of the atomic bomb the
term hard water is most likely a
stand-in for heavy water which is also
known as deuterium and works as an
essential element and atomic radiation
however during his efforts in separating
the elements pertaining to their
experiment Jay Garrick goes to light a
cigarette and in the process knocks over
the mixture because he's exposed to the
gaseous form of heavy water the
chemicals overwhelm his senses causing
him to pass out with the professor
arriving the following morning and
finding him collapsed on the floor Jay
Garrick is immediately taken to the
hospital for medical treatment
furthermore according to one of the
doctors who had been analyzing Jay
exposure to heavy water by physical
contact causes the person to move with
incredible reflexes but because Jay
Garrick inhaled the gases the element
has effectively bonded with his genes
allowing him to walk
Hauk run and fink at superhuman speeds
now again DC takes liberties with the
idea of heavy water by essentially
making things up on the spot and truth
exposure to heavy water in atomic
radiation would most likely result in a
grisly death by radiation sickness but
because atomic energy was a relatively
new concept and because fans are more
concerned with the introduction of new
heroes as opposed to the science behind
the development of their powers the
basis for Jay Garrick's introduction was
taken without question but furthermore
because Superman was a standout star DC
ensured that while Jay Garrick was able
to move extremely fast his speed and
well within his comics did not
overshadow Superman as a result the
original depiction of Jay Garrick speed
has left ambiguous except to say that he
may be able to outrun a bullet at some
point in the future and so after
discovering that his physiology had been
modified to allow for SuperSpeed Jay
Garrick immediately goes about
impressing Joan meeting her as she
travels to the library for a book Jay
races to the library grabs a book for
her and returns again because this is
the golden age like many of the origins
of the time while the idea of Superman
Batman and other superheroes existing in
the same universe had not been
established DC simply goes with the idea
that the arrival of superpowers is
accepted without question and so asking
Joan on a date she accepts Jays advances
but only under the condition that he
applies himself to football and helps a
football team win the state championship
and so using a SuperSpeed Jay is easily
able to help the team win the game and
in turn when to the hearted Joan
so because jay garrick's initial
introduction came during the dawn of the
golden age and the introduction of comic
book superheroes in truth with the Green
Lantern Alan Scott Hawkman and Jay
Garrick their popularity was largely due
to the luck of the draw and that for
whatever reason fans latched on to their
characters as a result having undertaken
the name the flash to reflect how people
viewed him when he was traveling at
SuperSpeed Jay Garrick became the main
star of the flash comics serving as the
first story in each issue furthermore
while the early stories were written by
Gardner Fox once the metaphorical
training wheels were off and Jay Garrick
had demonstrated the ability to stand on
his own by the summer of 1940 the flash
was used to launch the title all-star
comics which like many of DC's anthology
series at the time served to introduce
various characters to the chemical
landscape but was also famous for
introducing the Justice League
predecessor the Justice Society of
America as the first and only team of
superheroes and comic books at the time
the Justice Society was wildly popular
among fans in that it centered on a
combination of DC's top to your
characters like the flash and Green
Lantern but also included second to your
characters like Sandman the atom and
Hawkman furthermore with the Justice
Society acting as a catalyst to continue
the popularity of Jay Garrick by 1941 he
received his own solo series in the form
of all flash quarterly a series that was
originally released in June September
December and March of 1941 and 1942 for
its first five issues and because of his
popularity was switched over to a
bimonthly series with issue number six
however following the conclusion of
World War two
the popularity of superheroes was
beginning to crumble and while flash was
one of only a handful of characters that
survived into the 1950s with flash
comics issue number 104 1956 of the
close of the Golden Age and DC's
relaunch other publications by starting
the Silver Age the flash title was
cancelled due to poor sales and
reintroduced with Barry Allen standing
in as the new flash located in Central
City furthermore the problem that fans
were faced with was a reconciliation
between the fact that Superman Aquaman
Batman and Wonder Woman had all
maintained the same identities from
their introductions in the 1930s and the
1940s up until the current time but the
identities of the flash and the Green
Lantern had not
where this question largely went
unanswered by DC for five years in 1961
this continuity issue was finally
addressed in a story called the flash of
two worlds taking place in flash volume
1 issue number 123 the story saw DC
reintroducing Jay Garrick by having
himself a Barry Allen meet for the first
time centering on Barry Allen as he
performs tricks to the light of children
what DC established was at the various
realities that make up their multiverse
all exists in the same space but vibrate
at different frequencies figure it this
way the different realities of DC's
multiverse are similar to individuals
humming at different pitches if a person
were wanting to travel into another
reality they would have to hum at the
same pitch of the reality they were
wanting to enter with that in mind while
in the middle of one of his tricks Barry
Allen goes to vibrate himself and effort
to appear invisible unintentionally
vibrating through the barrier between
realities he finds himself in Keystone
City the home of Jay Garrick from the
Golden Age deducing the fact that he has
arrived at an alternate reality Barry
Allen visits the home of Jay Garrick and
in the process provides us as the reader
with an explanation of how Jay Garrick
existence relates to bury himself what
we're told is that in Barry Allen's
reality Jay Garrick never existed as the
flash instead Jay Garrick was a caliber
character written by Gardner Fox with
all the same details as they were
depicted in the Golden Age of comics
while this was initially confusing to
fans Barry Allen clear this up by
stating that the Golden Age of comics
from the introduction of Superman up
until 1956 took place in an alternate
reality called earth 2 and that the
Silver Age which began in 1956 was a
reality called earth 1 furthermore the
stories of Jay Garrick and Barry Allen's
reality with a result of Gardner Fox
dreaming and literally entering Jay
Garrick's universe and creating stories
based off those experiences while this
was far from the cleanest approach in
terms of introducing an alternate
reality in a seamless and non confusing
way in the end it served his purpose by
allowing DC to fold Jay Garrick into
their run of publications as well as
having both himself and Barry Allen
team-up and future stories however
because Barry Allen was the star flash
at the time following the reintroduction
of Jay Garrick Barry's ability to move
at the speed of light was maintained
while Jay Garrick speed was slightly
increased and granted him the ability to
travel 20 times faster than the speed of
sound
without being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it and I will catch you guys
later peace